I took up the escape artistry thing on a
peculiar sort of event it was that I was
working in Quebec City at the polio al I
think it was called a nightclub there
and a couple of cops came by and we're
eyeing me from the for the side of the
stage and they came to me afterwards and
showed me a pair of handcuffs and said
could you get out of these and I said oh
yeah sure I
they're simple oxen well we'll we'll see
after the show and I said yeah sure okay
thinking I would never see them again I
packed up and I was leaving the dressing
room and suddenly they showed up in the
stairway I said oh I forgot about that
so I went downstairs and they put a pair
of handcuffs on me out in the street but
should the amusement of people passing
by I can assure you and they opened the
squad car door for me I got in one side
and got out the other side with the
handcuffs off now that sort of got their
attention they hadn't seen that before
but I will confide in you that handcuff
locks are very very simple locks and I
was pretty well set up for it and ready
for it but as they looked at me in some
astonishment and said well did you think
you could break out of our Jail and I
said well show me the jail oh they put
me in the back of the squad car and off
we went and the next morning the
headlines of the the Quebec Soleil was
the name of the paper came out with
Layton all Randy save Adela please on
the Quebec
that means the amazing Randi and I'd
never used that title before I was up
until then I was the great Randall you
see but the amazing Randi escapes from
the jail of Quebec or the Quebec jail it
laid a bit of news and I went to the
nightclub that night the mayor met me at
the door I said forget that birds and
the rings and all that sort of thing
he said do something in the escape
business so I went out there and I I did
a thing and that's how I got into it but
it made it made a good reputation from
me I broke out of 22 jails around the
world in my career and all legally that
is
yes I've never actually been locked up
in one where I well there was one
occasion I won't get into the teeth
well it wasn't much of a feat really at
the time I must say because I was much
younger at he was 52 at the age when he
did that and I was I think 22 so I had
the advantage the physical advantage
over old Harry and so I I took a certain
amount of credit for it but I did break
his record by a few minutes and I did it
several times after that at around the
world in different countries and in
different venues and I increased my
record to 1 hour and 44 minutes of being
sealed up in the steel coffin underwater
well it's a matter of using some common
sense to start with you don't want to
use up a lot of oxidant I got a very
good night's sleep I did it on the Today
Show on NBC with Dave Garroway as a
matter of fact I was the host at that
time that was many many moons ago and I
rested up very thoroughly I stayed at
the hotel Shelton where there was a
swimming pool in New York City and I
slept well
and I must say that when I got into the
into the coffin there I was sorry to
think well maybe maybe I'll make an hour
so I made an hour and 31 minutes in that
particular episode but I just breathed
in a very shallow manner I didn't take
big deep breaths use a lot of oxygen and
I relaxed and I had I had good assurance
I had headphones on so I was listening
to what was happening outside they would
consult with me right now and then I had
a microphone on my chest I just took it
easy i temped my metabolism rate way
down and at the end of the hour in 31
minutes though I was really doing this
kind of a thing had to take every bit of
oxygen I could possibly manage because
you are rebreathing the area so you're
not using all of the Archard on every
breath of course but it was tough it was
rather tough I subsequently learned that
I could do it as I said it for an hour
and 44 minutes at the last time I did it